I've read two different articles about avocados, one saying they're histamine activators and
another saying to eat them as a low histamine food. What do you think? It goes back to our
histamine question and this we get a lot because this not so fairly on avocados but if you look at
you google low histamine foods on the internet and you're going to get different lists and the
reason is is because if we brought foods to a laboratory to test them for histamine levels, it depends
on how old the foods are that are that we're testing that is going to be that will coordinate to
the level of histamines we find in them. So if our avocados are overly ripe to probably
going to have more histamines in it than avocados that are less ripe. I guess we could probably see
that with every food. So the older the food is the more histamines that are going to be in it,
that's why the lists are going to be different. So again I would say eat them with balance,
eat them with balance, eat them with balance, eat them with other foods, eat them with foods,
other things. So